so
[Music]
here therefore consciousness or the mode
in which essence is for consciousness
itself that is its shape is in fact
identical with its self-consciousness
this shape is itself a
self-consciousness it is thus at the
same time an object in the mode of
immediate being and this being likewise
immediately has the significance of pure
thought of absolute being
the absolute being which exists as an
actual self-consciousness seems to have
come down from its eternal simplicity
but by thus coming down it has in fact
attained for the first time to its own
highest essence
for it is only when the notion of
essence has reached its simple purity
that it is the absolute abstraction
which is pure thought and hence the pure
individuality of self just as
on account of its simplicity it is also
the immediate or being
what is called sense consciousness is
just this pure abstraction it is this
thinking for which being is the
immediate thus the lowest is at the same
time the highest the revealed which has
come forth wholly onto the surface is
precisely therein the most profound that
the supreme being is seen hurt etc as an
immediately present self-consciousness
this therefore is indeed the
consummation of its notion and through
this consummation that being is
immediately present qua supreme being
paragraph
760 it's not all that long and it might
be tempting
to skim through it because there's all
this metaphysical typical hegelian
language and there's some really cool
stuff that happened in the paragraph
just prior to it which is a longer
paragraph
and there's a lot of similarly cool
stuff that is being
revealed being
opened up in the paragraph
following at
761 which is also a longer paragraph
and you know this might be a time for a
little bit of a digression
thinking about what do we do when we're
reading this text
and
there are some times when it may seem
like hegel is going down a blind alley
or wasting our time dithering about
before he gets to
what we could call the main point what
are you really getting at hagel
and you know i won't say that that's
never ever the case that's definitely
not the case here in this paragraph
there are some important things that are
being worked through
and worked out but we would have to
think about the implications of them as
well as wrapping our head around what it
is that hegel himself is saying
and you know you could think of this in
a way as
hegel himself thinking through
these matters getting them arranged
before he moves
back into the the flow of the text
and gets a bit more specific about
what's going on and what is going on
here well we are talking about
incarnation as we've already seen
in the previous paragraph and when we
talk about this term incarnation what
are we referencing well what hegel
considers to be
the the revealed religion one of several
revealed religions but also the absolute
religion christianity and you might say
that in some respects hegel is like that
old joke about the guy who says when i
talk about religion i mean christianity
and when i talk about christianity i
mean protestant christianity and when i
talk about protestant christianity i
think the way that the old saying goes
is i i'm thinking of the church of
england so there's like this specifying
going on now
you know is it merely doctrinal
controversies and polemics that's
motivating hegel no he's he does think
of
christianity as
putting something
new and you might even say unique
or to use one of the words that we've
got here
individual einstein heights right
individuality
onto the table and
incarnation is
different than
other religious perspectives which might
say you know god will reveal himself to
all different people in different ways
at different points in time and you know
the revelation
could be in terms of something coming
down from on high some primal word or
some writings you know hey take this
down here's some dictation from god or
from an angel or pick whatever you want
or it could be the revelation
of and through
a person and that's what we're talking
about here and that's what we're talking
about in the previous paragraphs and
that's where we're going in the next
paragraphs
so
one of the key questions that we can ask
before we jump into the text
is
how often
and
where
is
this self-revelation
through a kind of lowering a kind of
entering into the world the eternal
entering into time if we would like to
use kierkegaard's own framing of this in
philosophical fragments where he has a
philosopher talking about this sort of
stuff right and kierkegaard is a critic
of hegel but kierkegaard is also taking
some stuff
from hegel
um
can this happen
in multiple times in multiple places
i mean one
way of thinking about this is well god
is so good that or
the divine or whatever it is is so good
that it sends these
revealers
these self-revealers
throughout the the cosmos
into maybe multiple worlds
and multiple places in time and hegel is
saying
just once
just once is more
is in a certain way
more essential
more god-like than
uh understandings where there are
multiple revelations all right so let's
that's enough going back and forth about
that let's jump into the text so we got
something really interesting happening
in the very
first couple sentences
here therefore
consciousness the voice sign right
or he says the mode the visa
in which
uh
essence vasen is for consciousness
itself so the way in which
essence or being in this case the
supreme being is for consciousness it's
shape it's gestalt
right it's a pregnant word right there
is what
here's where the english can be a little
bit misleading
is identical is equal to
its self-consciousness helps be with
side and not just self-consciousness in
general but
it's self-consciousness
right
so consciousness and self-consciousness
are
now on this term gleick which we've
talked about many times
in earlier paragraphs yes identical can
work as a translation equal can also
work
but we could also say equivalent to
could work its consciousness is
equivalent to
its self-consciousness
and what does that actually
mean for us well hegel goes on
and develops this this shape this
gestalt
is itself a
notice the the term there a
self-consciousness
it is thus he says at the same time an
object a gegenstand right in the mode of
immediate being and this being
likewise immediately now notice this
this very important term that kind of
qualifies things does he go on and say
this being is pure thought is absolute
being
no
this being he says has the
significance or we might say the meaning
right the meaning of pure thought
and absolute being now what is what is
doing that well it's the
self-consciousness and here we ought to
pause for a second
think back to the self-consciousness
section what are some of the key things
that we know about self-consciousness
self-consciousness does not exist as an
isolated monad by itself
self-consciousness always exists and has
itself in another self-consciousness and
its relation with that
self-consciousness and that
self-consciousness is relation with
itself and what is it that
self-consciousness is looking for what
is it that it desires right what is it
hunger for what is its beginner for it
is for recognition or acknowledgement on
air cannon and this recognition early on
in the self-consciousness section is a
rather crude thing that we see being
worked out in interpersonal dynamics and
economics and political relations of
master and slave and then we have you
know stoicism skepticism unhappy
consciousness this recognition raises
itself and becomes more complex over and
over again throughout the reason mostly
the um i mean you could say it's there
in the um
phenol phrenology
and physiognomy section as what's
missing right and then we see it there
as well in the sections where we're
talking about lived practical
philosophical points of view and then we
get into the spirit section and it's
looking for it there and then we get
into religion and religion is also a
craving and looking for
recognition recognition in relationship
to another self-consciousness so if that
self-consciousness
could be
god
then maybe maybe we can get the
recognition we're really
really looking for as believers or
worshipers or followers maybe we can
have the certainty and the truth that
we've been seeking for all of this time
all right so again a digression back to
the text again
um
this this uh
object this being
has the significance or the meaning the
doitung of pure rhine thought denkin
or of absolute being and being here is
not zion being here is vasen the essence
that we were talking about here the
essence that is for
consciousness all right so this is
pretty complex already
now he goes on and he says
here's where you get this important
transition
the absolute being
which exists as
an actual self-consciousness okay
how does it exist as an actual
self-consciousness
this is where we have to talk about
a
coming down to our level
of miserable human beings this is an
overcoming of the unhappy
self-consciousness or the unhappy
consciousness which earlier in the
religion section hegel did call the
unhappy self-consciousness so a little
slip of the lip there that uh works out
quite well
um
what's what's going on
in order for god not just to be
substance
in order for god
not just to be
self
in order for god not just to be subject
of predicates god has to be
self-consciousness
can god be self-consciousness for us
without
taking on flesh without
adopting a
persona and not just a person like god
the father god the son god the holy
spirit as we talk about in trinitarian
christian theology
but a genuine persona as
a human person
i mean this is worth thinking about
can we ascribe self-consciousness to god
or to gods
without kind of mythologizing i mean
think about the greek myths gods are
basically
sort of like superhuman uh human beings
and they do human-like stuff like screw
around on each other and get in fights
and trick each other and you know
they're not like speculating about the
the very nature of the universe i mean
zeus administers justice but in kind of
a slip shot way
you know what about the biblical god
you know the god encountered through
first the hebrew scriptures
and then later on in testimony well this
is where it gets different right because
that jesus fellow
is at least in the christian scriptures
at least in the canonical ones and even
in a lot of the non-canonical ones
supposed to be god
a self-consciousness who lives
who who lives
like one of us
maybe not completely like one of us
right how many of you are carpenters for
example right how many of you turn water
into wine that's not not all i mean i've
never done that i've done some carpentry
in my time but the other stuff not so
much right all right back to back to the
text once again
so hegel tells us
the absolute being which exists as an
actual self-consciousness
seems to have come down
gasteigen sort of like
climbing down you know there's an
activity involved there coming down from
what
coming down from its eternal aviga right
uh everlasting
simplicity it's einfach height
and so we have an interesting uh
contrast of heights here height being
that you know the
suffix which
makes something into kind of like a a
noun a substantive state so we have
einfacheit the
you know unity or
the
uh simplicity right einfach simple
um literally folded once right
and then einsteinite
right
individuality
um and it's gonna be
both of those but it comes down from one
to the other
so he says by coming down
it has
attained
for the first time
to its highest essence
well this is actually kind of
mind-blowing
let's think about this for a minute
hegel is not saying that god
coming down to us poor slobs here
uh the eternal entering into time again
to use you know this wonderful
uh
way of expressing it
you know god coming into history is
another way of framing it
this doesn't mean that god is doing this
as a mere concession like well you know
i made the world made all these people
i'm way up here
things are going haywire down here i
gotta send like a messenger you know an
avatar or a representative or something
like that down there
no hegel is saying this is a
more developed
higher
more to its essence conception
of the divine on the part of human
beings
so he goes on and he says
it's attained for the first time its
highest essence only when the notion the
begrave the
concept of essence has reached its
simple purity that it is the absolute
abstraction which is pure thought
and hence the pure individuality of self
just as on account of its simplicity
it's also the immediate or
being so something is
happening here in this coming down
this
condensation of god within
the human world not not just within the
world not just entering as sort of a a
blip that then takes on human flesh no
god coming into human culture
and at a particular place at a
particular time with a
particular
social milieu
right
so what does god come down as this
immediately present the immediate uh
isn't actually in there in the germans
just scientists right being
self-consciousness
a self-consciousness of
a human being jesus christ we're gonna
find out right
somebody who is going to be um
carrying out teaching and ministry and
providing us with all sorts of puzzles
and parables and paradoxes to think
about and teaching a way of life and
making decisions and eating food and you
know presumably also doing things like
you know bathing himself and going to
the bathroom and chit chatting with
people about random stuff right
this is god entering into
our
matrix of self-consciousness at least
for those who are there right because
then he goes on and he says
what is called sense consciousness is
just this pure abstraction it is this
thinking
for which being is the immediate and and
this you know think back to self
not self certainty sense certainty right
the very first
substantive section of this after the
preface after the introduction
and turns out that you know
what we take to be
the thing in itself there's always much
more to it and we go through this entire
consciousness section to figure that out
well you know something like that is
happening
here because we can actually see this
person
now there's there's some you know trans
formations you could say or trans
valuations if you like going on here
as well
the lowest
is at the same time the highest
so you know the first shall be last the
last shall be first is this a reference
to that that verse
you know not necessarily but that is
certainly part of the dynamic
the lowest is some
guy who sweats and stinks sometimes and
goes around and maybe you know when he
preaches the sermon on the mount
stutters a bit we don't actually know
what we know are the
accounts provided of him
probably idealized in the gospels
remember too that hegel
in in his time there is a lot going on
with thinking through these texts the
higher criticism is coming into being
and people are saying well these might
not be perfectly
accurate depictions of what was going on
they might be conditioned by the culture
in which
this is taking place and by literary
conventions and all sorts of things like
that so there's one thing the lowest is
the same time the highest
the revealed which has come forth wholly
on the surface
is also the most profound
there is a
depth
to this
self-revealing god
who has taken
place in human you know society and life
and
what he seems to be doing on the surface
might contain
a great depth i mean do we have to
assume that for every single thing every
single
word that is preserved maybe not maybe
some of the time he was just joking
around with his friends and you know
like freud says maybe sometimes a cigar
is just a cigar we don't have to
symbologize
everything but
you don't know until you start thinking
about it do you and so you start probing
into it so he says the supreme being
this is the supreme being this
self-consciousness
is seen and heard
as an immediately present
self-consciousness
this
therefore
is the consummation of its notion the
notion of the divine in relation to
human beings in relation to
self-consciousnesses consciousnesses and
self-consciousnesses you know fused
together which is part of the religion
section at the very beginning trying to
figure out what the hell is this god
what what surpasses us what exceeds us
what teaches us how we ought to live and
how we ought not to live what can give
us guidance
that's being heard and seen at least by
those in proximity i mean afterwards we
get testimony
you know things are talked about written
down stories are circulated around but
for some there is this immediately
present
uh capacity and that's a
consummation so for landon right
we could also say perfection we could
also say
the fulfillment right being brought to
its its telos its end
revealing itself in the process
revealing what the telos of the divine
actually is
this is really interesting stuff isn't
it because again think about
it you know it might not be completely
unique to christianity maybe the
revelation of god as love is also
connected to the notion of the divine as
compassion as we find in other religions
right
but this is in a
person who is love incarnate who is
truth incarnate
and this is a
bringing this notion of essence to its
fulfillment
again this is supposed to be like the
consummate religion the fulfilled
promise of religion and so he says
through this consummation that being is
immediately present
supreme being for those who hear and see
and believe
and live in connection even if they
don't fully understand
this is god itself revealing it as
person
as self-consciousness who they can
engage and this is a very
powerful thing this is a
for hegel
an important
transformation of human possibility and
human history this is not just an idea
this is a lived reality
for people of being in contact with god
in a
radically new way that they barely can
wrap their heads around but which is
going to play a massive
massively important role
in what follows
and in human history so again i want to
go back to something i was saying at the
beginning there's there's actually a lot
going on in this paragraph if we go
under the you know surface of just
talking about metaphysics and we
sandwich it in between these two longer
in some respects more concrete
paragraphs that are perhaps on on the
surface much more interesting this turns
out to be a really
important stopping point
for us to consider
what is going on here
for human self-consciousness in relation
to a divine
self-consciousness that is able to be
self-consciousness by becoming
human by taking on flesh
by taking on place and time by taking on
all the things that make us what we are
you